[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens écoutez pour les
emprunter manière occasionnelle je
trouve que selon les lignes on peut
effectivement avoir des différences
marquées
tout se passe très bien quel que soit le
le créneau horaire si vous prenez la 13
que je prends occasionnellement dans les
choses peuvent aller vite compliqué vous
les premiers en famille alors en famille
oui alors là effectivement j'ai la
chance m'a d'avoir plus de trois enfants
donc je bénéficie d'un tarif qui me
permet effectivement de prendre
relativement régulièrement sans que sa
grève non l'objet pour vous retrouver
effectivement à faire des rachats de
deux tickets assez rapide ça va c'est
quoi c'est pour les transports ouais
c'est mon frérot pourrait dire ça
mauvaise pioche faut laisser une bonne
fin de journée
mon futur c'est clair et finalement ça
perdu pas mal navigué transporter et
votre haine on conçoit une passe une
farce parce qu'on m'a déjà fait du coup
ils pensez quoi des transports en commun
parle je trouve qu'ils sont bien
pratiques
il ya parfois des problèmes mais
généralement c'est bien c'est utile il
ya du monde mais faut s'y faire
vous les prenez souvent très souvent way
tous les jours et vous et votre sera
elle en pense quoi
mon frère il en pense tu en penses quoi
sert frau s'est tenue en métro j'avais
en rollers moi j'étais un rider 2 ou
fraude side qui part d'un an que son
rôle de parent non non non et ce avec
atteint soit prudent rail soit férié
[Musique]